we've already learned a lot about waze
and we're going to connect it a bit
to technology especially the technology
that most of us use most frequently and
that's our cell phone
so pause this video and think if you can
list
all of the ways that your cell phone has
to utilize
or deal with or generate waves
all right so the first thing that some
of you
might have realized is that your cell
phone has to deal
with sound waves so you have sound
traveling through the air your phone has
to
detect that sound and then in
most cases it needs to digitize that
sound and we did
other videos where we talked about
sampling sound waves so that you can
store it as
digital information and then depending
what's happening that detection is going
to happen with your microphone
and if you were recording something say
recording a video or recording an audio
file
that digitized sound wave would then be
stored and then if you wanted to play it
back
it would have to be turned back into a
sound wave which could then be emitted
by your microphone now it could also be
that you're on
let's say a video call or you are having
an actual phone call the original
purpose of
phones and so then that digitized
information
is going to be transmitted
to a cell tower that could be tens of
miles away
and i always find that amazing because a
cell phone really has
it trans it doesn't transmit in a
particular direction it kind of
transmits in every direction
so it's got to be pretty powerful to get
to that cell tower that might be around
five or ten or even more miles away and
then of course if you're having a
conversation
that cell tower is transmitting
electromagnetic waves in a bunch of
different directions
and then this cell phone says hey that's
the signal for me
and it can take that digital information
and then it could use that to generate
a wave pattern which is then emitted by
the microphone again which you then hear
so sound waves is clearly a big part of
what's going on with a lot of technology
not just
cell phones obviously if you have a
stereo system if you have a television
sound waves are heavily utilized or at
least you have to deal with them
now what other type of wave well you
might be saying
light waves which would be correct but
i'm going to generalize a little bit
more and say
electromagnetic waves of which light
wave
light waves are a type of
electromagnetic waves
how do you use light waves well a modern
smartphone or cell phone
will have a camera and so it needs a way
to detect
light waves so it will detect them
and once again it will digitize it will
store
and then of course it has this nice big
screen here
so it needs a way to take that digitized
information and then
generate light waves every pixel on the
screen
can generate different frequencies of
light waves or at least give the
appearance
altogether of generating different
frequencies of
light waves now light waves are not the
only type of electromagnetic wave
we've talked about having to communicate
with a cell tower that could be 5
10 15 even further miles away
well those waves it's using to connect
with your cell tower
those are radio waves which are another
type of electromagnetic waves
now are we done well just to make sure
we can look at this little key here that
you see at the top of a cell phone
and you can see that cell signal that
tells you how good of a
radio signal it is getting from the cell
tower
but you can also see this wi-fi signal
here so wi-fi uses
different frequencies of radio waves to
communicate with
the local network wherever you are but
once again
that is more radio waves so i will let
you go i encourage you as you learn
anything in any topic
always look at the world around you and
see how these concepts that you're
learning in school or that you're
learning in
say a physics class are connected to
things you do every moment of your life